my greatest achievement this morning I
nearly like drowned on the way here I
was in a taxi with bakari sweat and the
driver was like
every
I'm sorry
it's like waterboarding myself on Wheels
I [__] hate that yeah but other than
that I'm good it'll be very hot and I've
just arrived and the guys are like by
the way the air conditioning doesn't
work here it's not that bad it's a nice
it's one of the nicer days the Studio's
gone downhill
walked in there's like a landfill site
by the window yeah that's the rubbish
Corner
yeah we've just accumulated a lot of
[__] was I'm sorry Chris it used to be
near the entrance yeah so now it's in
like a little bit more of an
inconspicuous we thought we'd clean
things up for you but uh you know yeah
apparently our efforts were just not
seen just a big pile of rubbish
speaking of a big pile of rubbish you've
left Sendai
I thought it was gonna be a segue to the
book there
yeah it's the biggest the biggest thing
is that you move to Tokyo so you're here
now finally yeah
um
I don't know I'm kind of wish I hadn't
come here
it's like seven degrees warmer here than
Sunday it's only like two hours away by
bullet train right but yeah yeah
um it's been good but like getting
around Tokyo is a bit [__] in the summer
like I'm living off of picari sweat my
blood is like 50 for curry and it needs
to be because just drinking water
doesn't do it you need salts why picara
and antioxidants antioxidants not
antioxidants what's the word wait wait I
think that's something that's from the
team from the man that brought you
osmosis
down here in Tokyo every other week for
like yeah something like yeah I mean the
novelty is sort of worn off very fast
given that I used to come to Tokyo so
much anyway yeah it's been good it's
been good to be nearby friends
yeah and like it it's it's cool like
we're just getting the newborn Japan
Studio set um the sets being built next
week and um it's being like doubled in
size you can finally fit my entire yeah
you guys in there yeah we've got the
Ramen Shop electronic store and now
there's going to be like a 1980s
Japanese living room
because one I think one criticism about
the brawn Japan set is it's very like
cold-hearted like the man that presents
the video it's very like a depressing
Ramen Shop yeah and that's kind of cool
but like well I mean you were kind of
going for like a cyber Punky aesthetic
anyway yeah yeah so that makes it up a
bit and yeah that's gonna be a lot of
fun but I've got a present for you oh
I remember when I moved here an American
colleague always talked about Chile and
I pretended to know what he was talking
about yeah
and then I was chilly right yeah but no
red wine would be complete without a
cheese board of course
a patronizing these small pieces
to cheese microscopic samples
foreign
because the other day when we were
hanging out you were talking about this
like brown cheese or something
you remembered it yeah you said to me I
like Norwegian Brown cheese yeah that's
like your new thing now
you made it sound really [__]
Insidious you like the moon of brown
cheese mate no dude okay when Chris and
I when Chris and I were hanging out the
other day it's the first thing you said
it's like how's it going by the way
Brown cheese
actual Banger and I'm like oh okay he's
no longer the camera be a man anymore
Norwegian bread I was like I'll try this
delicious food and they brought it out
it's amazing what is it what's cheese is
it remedies
I thought it's so good it's kind of like
caramelized cheese
what foods you're gonna like by how
unhealthy they are they're unhealthier
it is the more you're like so much
Camembert wasn't bad enough for me you
know how many calories can we pack into
this you know yeah we'll go to like
Yakitori and you know you'll have this
great you know I'm sure he's not it's
not I wouldn't say it's healthy it's not
terrible and of course without failure
it will get and it is [__] good
though we go to this one place and they
have like cheese but Chris will get like
four
dude that's what happened the other day
when we went drinking at this like
British pub he got two fish and chips to
himself he was supposed to tell anyone
about it oh my God
the fish the fish and chips in Japan are
[__] small size exactly I I I will
slam I've gotten fishing from that Pub
they are good yeah I know the one yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's good [__] and uh the fish and chips
was decent I will say it was like a
regular size steak it wasn't like it was
like
yeah
just being abused here
I just I go without fail if it's
unhealthy you will you will always be
like we should get it I'm like no
Christmas cycle 500 kilometers so Chris
I see you've relapsed from your uh chess
Boxing Day things been downhill going
thing's been down here there's one
boxing event and uh when was the last
date we had you on it's just just before
boxing right it was a simple time yeah
it was November I thought we were on you
uh you guys made a bet about you getting
a six-pack yeah he still hasn't he
didn't live up to his end of the deal
and he still hasn't I did pay it did you
actually I did I did donate it I'm not a
monster
thank you for cheese you're not you're
not a Monster yeah but it's hard to get
the wallet to open up sometimes that
this is his way of repaying him cheese
and wine I I lost the uh six pack bet
yeah I was putting a lot more questions
what was the BET what was the bet so it
was to get a six yeah
six weeks or something yeah in six weeks
by the time you guys did your cyclophone
[Music]
honestly I I should have trained more
for that cheers there's no two ways
about it but I was under a lot of
pressure at the time I was also writing
the damn book right so I'm like booking
one hand then getting smashed in the
face in the others yeah one of the
things people don't know about the first
cyclathon and the one of the smartest
decisions Chris made was that he was
gonna have a deadline for the book
whilst we're recycling remember so every
night you were like you're stressing out
and then you're like we'd all we you
know if we had a meal we'd go to bed 10
p.m normal time I'd charge my stuff and
go to bed wake up the next day because
oh I went to bed at three like why the
[__] did you go to the men we were
waking up at six Chris and then he's
like oh I had to write my book why would
you schedule the book at the same time
oh I thought I [__] myself
yeah I did and uh so is there one chap
from the book that's just like really
badly written from brain damage
just smashing the key
s
realize these are trash-taced glasses
available now on the trash day
I feel bad because I wanted to get you a
present Chris I try really really hard
under what I wonder what guys go that's
a bit really really hard to win a prize
at Connor's Charity Auction
I watched you in the audience with Sid
going like
I woke up at 10 A.M that morning and I
was like oh [__] I'm missing Connor's
show and I tuned in literally seconds
before you started doing the big mouth
thing yeah which went for an astonishing
eight thousand dollars yeah somehow for
something that was like a dodgy printout
that you guys
honestly
it went fragrand and that is astonishing
and um
what was your limit five grand oh [__]
yeah
[Music]
I can't believe that that was a real
happy ending to the to the story and as
I you know I don't look like big mouth
anymore right I'm metamorable yeah well
we're trying to bring you back don't
worry with all this cheese
bring him back to the Glory Days you
know Oblivion show me the show me the
real abroad in Japan but that was good
though it was a good auction and uh yeah
yeah did really well oh yeah yeah
no jokes wow I'm like you while you were
doing the big mouth auction you ate a
cracker from hell
yeah have you ever done it I haven't no
you want to try it no okay I because I
couldn't tell if you were like
deliberately like drawing out to get
more
it was really really [__] awful how
many scovilles was this thing I think
it's like the equivalent of like two
crushed up Carolina Reapers like funny
like 10 mil and that's what you have on
the trash taste 24 hours I had a ghost
pepper which is one level down from that
no it's like two two three oh two or
three okay yeah you had that on an
auction it's like yeah two of them how
are you not like physically sick all
over the state well because I have a
good choice I'm a good spice tolerant
but that was that next time that was
really pushing it the worst the worst
time I've ever had it is I was doing the
stream where one of my Pokemon died I
would I would take take one because I
thought I can handle the pepper and the
first one was fine um you know I was I
was in pain but it wasn't terrible but I
think there was some kind of like
follow-up punch that the second one did
get that away Navi we don't want to see
that
it gave me it gave me like a a follow-up
punch uh
uh yeah Carolina Reaper pepper Scorpion
Chili Pepper uh so scorpion Chili's the
second most Carolina Reaper all in one
you can smell it if you want I know it's
it's us it's vacuum sealed yes uh do not
eat if you're sensitive to spicy foods
allergic to Peppers nightshades or
pregnant
um yeah I think medical assistance
should you die yeah yeah so I took two
peppers like an hour after each other
and the second one I felt like nearly
put me in a coma it hurt my stomach so
bad to the point where I just couldn't
stream I had to like lie down for 30
minutes and like come back later and be
like sorry guys yeah it was a bold me so
that was dumb and this one wasn't that
bad because I had like a gallon of milk
right right and the milk helped so much
because everyone's like oh the next
day's worse but yeah the next day is
worse if it's not absolutely
encapsulated by one liter of milk so is
that would you say the worst thing
you've had like in terms of spice uh
yeah I think so God damn worst one by
the way it comes in a box shaped like a
coffin no less yeah that like sets you
up and then that's marketing yeah the
stomach pain was the worst part because
at the end of the auction I was trying
to do it did you did you get the cramps
yeah yeah I was getting the stomach
cramps the spicy pea I did get the spicy
did you get that
what's up
have you ever done like the ghost pepper
or like Carolina Reaper challenges or
anything like that no uh on a series of
Jane cross Japan last year with you we
had what was it called what it was
there's some [__] spicy food that
looked like Tar It was supposed to be
the spiciest thing in the world or
something I don't know
his house yeah oh we had to have it on a
toothpick right uh the sauce yeah I'd
have it on a toothpick and that like
incinerated my tongue and I was like it
was like pure that's probably pure like
capsaicin or we had that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah why do people do it I don't
know it's just like dangerous yeah what
I've learned is that like a little
toothpick is like fine because no matter
how much you take it's just not enough
to like spread around your mouth and
[__] it all up but having like the chip
or like the noodle soup like when it's
just completely coating your entire
organs those noodles [__] hurt that's
what that's when it really hurts yeah
and it was just like pain but I think
I'm I'm gonna lay off the spicy stuff
for a while
what other Thai food needs to stay
because when I drink I've become like a
human vacuum when I drink it it's just
like my normal appetite is just like
quadruples when I have like one beer for
me it's not it's not the day I'm getting
drunk It's The Hangover for some reason
when I wake up uh even if I'm on like a
diet if and I go out go drinking have a
like a moderate amount of drink I wake
up and I'm like first thing in the
morning I just crave a McDonald's
breakfast and I don't one's not enough I
have to order two now for me for me yeah
for me for me it's the like right at the
end of the night when I'm when we're
like all right let's go home and we're
heading to the taxi or the station or
whatever and I'm just like no that's
when you gotta fight go for it that
cheeky Little Mac when you have to fight
you have to I can't I can't my brain's
just like you need to eat two Big Macs
right now you have to just like okay
because it doesn't feel satisfying right
before you go to bed yeah you just feel
like [__] and then you wake up and
you're like I hate my life